foreign
[Applause]
they didn't teach us all our history
some stories got lost along the way
maybe if they had taught us everything
that happened
my brother would have left that knife
where he found it
I will play I won't quit
you know what I think we should do right
now go to the party come on let's go
if you play with me then I'll let you go
to your party and I won't call Mom okay
Joe
what game do you want to play
we'll all say I will play I won't quit
tell me demon
am I it
morgas
what did you do let's play
Marcus
are you ready to play hide and seek
Marcus why do you have that knife bye
why are you doing this
[Music]
go what is going on it's not him it's
the knife
found you
hey buddy you're just messing with us
right how about something
it only only happens when big wins
we win only one way to find out
I will play
I won't quit
let's play a new game